bienvenue à tous et leur de parlement
hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec catherine gilbert vosges au 4 juin
dit qu'elle est cette semaine dans
l'actualité le premier ministre y est
sur tous les fronts et ça commence à
londres en visite à la cites il a
déclaré sa flamme à l'entreprise et en
anglais s'il vous plaît mcdonald's bonne
foi vitesse mais le débat a surtout été
lancée auparavant laissé entendre qu'il
pourrait réformer l'assurance chômage
débat légitime dit-il dans son propre
camp tous ne sont pas d'accord
une épreuve de force et une négociation
à haut risque s'engage entre paris et
bruxelles la france doit envoyer son
projet de budget la commission pour le
moment ça coince bruxelles peut-il
retoqué ce budget ce sera notre zoom de
la semaine et puis c'est un coup de
grâce pour les quotas que ségolène royal
a mis fin au feuilleton at-elle plié
face à la menace des routiers manuel
valls à lui lui décision sage
alors que la transition énergétique est
en cours d'examen à l'assemblée
nationale les verts sont furieux et
justement notre invité cette semaine
françois de rugy
bonjour je leur député de
loire-atlantique et co président du
groupe écologiste à l'assemblée
nationale beaucoup d'actualité pour vous
on va en parler mais d'abord vous
n'échapperez pas à la tradition de cette
émission n'a demandé à quelques-uns de
vos collègues ce qu'il pensait de vous
écouter il n'est pas simplement le
porte-parole de lui même
et en cela je l'apprécié parce que je
sais qu'on peut discuter avec lui c'est
pas le cas de tous les députés
écologistes et je trouve que il incarne
bien l'écologie moderne sans ne peut pas
lui reprocher d'avoir été défendre un
point de vue qui n'avaient pas été
validées par le par le groupe et même
s'il est en opposition avec la vie que
le groupe a donné il le défend jusqu'au
bout je les admire pour ça parce que
c'est pas facile c'est un exercice très
compliqué à faire j'ai du respect et de
l'estimé pour tous ceux qui dans cet
hémicycle comme j'essaie de le faire
défendre les choses en lesquelles ils
croient quoique ça coûte quelle que soit
l'heure du jour et de la nuit
et quelles que soient les circonstances
les sas estime si je peux faire un
reproche à monsieur de régis et que
hilali là le bon mot un peu facile
peut-être qu'il gagnerait en percussion
de temps en temps à être un peu moins
mordants et un peu plus d'une forme
douce c'est ce que je pense en tout cas
c'est à la tête d'un groupe qui a
presque autant de voix différentes que
deux membres pourquoi tous entre cette
cacophonie comment vous faites pour la
synthèse non franchement je crois que
c'était tous les groupes parlementaires
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat ont
des individualités fortes d'ailleurs
pour une raison simple c'est vrai il ya
beaucoup oui mais si vous voulez que
l'on parle des frondeurs du parti
socialiste des divisions au sein de
l'ump parlé à tout le monde au sein de
votre groupe sans problème oui mais nous
essayons toujours de construire des
positions collectives
et puis quand vraiment ce n'est pas
possible on va pas faire semblant donc
il nous est arrivé d'avoir des votes
différents au sein du groupe est de dire
pourquoi est en quelque sorte ont fait
oeuvre de transparence
nous nous préférons avec barbara pompili
les deux co présidents de groupe que
nous sommes déjà d'ailleurs le fait
d'avoir deux coprésidents c'était une
volonté de collégialité pour avoir des
positions évidemment commune
après oui il ya des personnalités au
sein du groupe est bon ça fait aussi
partie non seulement de la vie politique
mais de la vie tout court
vous n'avez pas trop facile du tout je
le répète mais je vous pose quand même
nom et pourquoi voudrait
et vous que cela gêne sur différentes
nous avons une députée de plus nous
étions 17 nous sommes maintenant 18 et
par ailleurs elle a une expérience qui
est précieuse qui est celle du
gouvernement et elle est la seule au
sein du groupe écologiste d'ailleurs à
avoir cette expérience gouvernementale
peut-être qu'un jour il y en aura
d'autres mais pour l'instant elle est la
seule et c'est une expérience précieuse
qu'elle peut nous faire partager alors
reviendra un petit peu plus sur vous sur
votre e-réputation tout ce que vous
faites sur le web ce sera à la fin de
cette émission va commencer par dérouler
la semaine et ça commence par un a dit
manuel valls est à la city alors vous
connaissiez le jem l'entreprise en
version française en version allemande
mais la voix ça la voici maintenant en
version anglaise
il était dans le temple de la finance à
londres
ahmed tazir à londres un des fiefs du
french bashing manuel valls n'est pas en
terrain conquis il le sait pauline ma
vie rires avec son homologue britannique
devant le 10 downing street
la rencontre intervient alors que la
france se voit reprocher de ne pas en
faire assez pour réduire ses déficits
david cameron lui conduit une politique
d'austérité budgétaire qui s'accompagne
cette année d'une prévision de forte
croissance de 3 5% devant les caméras le
premier ministre britannique reste
diplomate
bien que nous soyons issus de familles
politiques différentes je suis certain
que nous avons beaucoup à partager en
terme d'expérience oui je suis ravi de
vous accueillir ici
mais le credo de manuel valls et
l'entreprise après l'avoir répété devant
le medef devant les patrons allemands
fin septembre il leur dit à la city de
londres
le temple de la finance mondiale et en
anglais s'il vous plaît j'aime les
entreprises et grâce à la traduction
vous l'entendez mais je vais le dire en
anglais d'une autre manière parce que
c'est important de le dire ici à la cité
my one and his propre business
et l'on découvre un manuel valls
polyglotte un discours éloigné de celui
de françois hollande pour qui
l'adversaire c'était la finance le
premier ministre poursuivra sa tournée
aux pays bas et au luxembourg le 20
octobre
alors si vous êtes promesses en attend
la traduction donc néerlandaise avec
impatience
plus sérieusement je crois que c'est un
peu un faux débat ça moi aller à la city
et non pas la cité comme l'a dit le
premier ministre à la city de londres je
vois pas tellement l'intérêt je le dis
franchement le symbole me paraît pas
très bon pourquoi aller chercher des
espèces de brevet de respectabilité
là-bas avoir des échanges avec les
britanniques veulent m'enfermer oui je
réforme oui mais je crois pas que vous
savez je crois pas que la city sous un
exemple de réformes et l'esprit
réformateur je vous dire pourquoi parce
que chaque fois qu'on a essayé de
réformer la finance qui est trop
spéculative chacun en convient et bien
qui est-ce qui s'est opposé avec
vraiment de la façon la plus farouche
possible c'est le gouvernement
britannique sous la pression de la city
en revanche que l'on dise pour répondre
à votre première question mcgovern 6 pro
business mon gouvernement et pro
business et que ça fasse quasiment la
une des médias les bras m'en tombent
vous imaginez un premier disque aurait
dit je suis anti business je n'aime pas
là encore je déteste les entreprises
mais ce serait absurde de l'entreprise
mais de la finance par exemple été à
londres
on était à londres et en fait c'est un
business est quand même plus large que
la finance je l'espère ou alors si le
business on blesse et ses errances et
françois de rugy
au début sur la critique de la finance
on a bien compris ce que voulait dire on
est loin de la city mais on a quand même
du discours de françois hollande ou
bourges et mondeville c'est la finance
il y a là c'est sur un décalage oui et
je constate un décalage très bon et vous
savez cette phrase aussi sur mon ennemi
c'est la finance voilà ça c'est des
phrases de campagne elles auront des
symboles et puis après alors on joue
avec les symboles et à force de jouer
uniquement avec les symboles la
politique elle n'avance pas et aimer ce
symbole a fait le tour de nos de la
presse de nos partenaires européens qui
retiennent c'est cette image de un
premier ministre socialiste qui vient à
londres avec ce genre de phrase qui
représente seulement la france des
réformes celle qui marche c'est une
bonne chose ça pour ma de pennant part
que le premier ministre ait vendre en
quelque sorte la d'avancé qu'il a
expliqué sa politique dans d'autres pays
chez nos voisins c'est tout à fait
positif évidemment et ça prouve
d'ailleurs qui a pas que le président de
la république qui s'occupe de d'actions
internationales moi je préfère c'est
vrai quand il va en italie avec matteo
renzi ou là je crois qu'il peut y avoir
un axe qui est à la fois réformateur pro
européens mais qui dit la politique
européenne doit changer ça ça me paraît
beaucoup plus intéressant
un bol tout à l'heure et je vous disais
tout à l'heure aussi que mon amie stella
fillon vous l'avez rappelé et c'était
une phrase qui date de 2012
nous sommes en 2014 c'est fini ce temps
là pour ce gouvernement
non monsieur je crois pas changé je
crois pas que le gouvernement soit
devenu l'ami de la finance et tout c'est
encore une fois toutes ces phrases on en
crève
on étouffe d'être uniquement sur les
symboles des totems soyons dans le
concret et le contre et c'est aussi
cette taxe à 75% klein ou la taxe sur
les transactions financières sur
laquelle on avance mais en effet qui est
ce qui résiste c'est le gouvernement
britannique
et c'est la city est par ailleurs un
événement ça on en parle peu la
désignation des commissaires européens
on va parler que je trouve ça assez
grave que parmi ces des commissaires il
ya un commissaire anglais qu'ils soient
justement chargé des bornes alors on en
parle
la politique économique de la france est
aussi regardé par bruxelles qui
surveille désormais de très près le
budget de paris la france devra-t-elle
revoir son projet de budget pour 2015
bruxelles n'a encore rien dit mais la
rumeur a couru suscitant interrogations
et indignation à l'assemblée mardi
notamment lors des questions au
gouvernement
la vie n'est pas encore officiel mais la
rumeur s'est vite répandue la commission
européenne pourrait demander à paris de
revoir son projet de budget pour 2015
à l'assemblée l'opposition s'est
immédiatement emparé du sujet la france
monsieur le premier ministre n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur sous peine de se voir
mis sous tutelle par la commission
européenne
les baisses d'impôts et de cotisations
en faveur des entreprises
les baisses d'impôt en faveur des
ménages la diminution des dépenses
ce sont exactement les chiffres que nous
avons annoncé au printemps dernier
exactement les mêmes même effort même
plus
même d'engagement il n'a aucune raison
d'être en contradiction avec les règles
européennes
quelques minutes plus tard le
gouvernement est à nouveau interpellé
cette fois c'est manuel valls qui défend
les engagements de la france
allez vous enclenchez réellement les
réformes nécessaires à notre pays
qu allez vous enfin répondre à bruxelles
et à nos partenaires
monsieur le député je vous le demande
plutôt que de critiquer la france plutôt
que de vous saisir de je ne sais quelle
thèse qui ne vient pas de l'autre pays
alors faites des propositions des
propositions crédibles
oui je vous attend sur ce débat n'est
pas sur ce jeu de quelles accusations
je ne sais quelle rumeur le budget de la
france c'est le budget une fois pour le
pays depuis 2013 bruxelles contrôler les
budgets de chaque état membre et peut
décider de sanctionner financièrement
les mauvais élèves selon la rumeur il
manquerait entre six et huit milliards
d'économies supplémentaires pour que le
déficit français soit dans les clous du
pacte de stabilité
on va en parler françois de rugy mais
d'abord revenons sur ce nouveau pouvoir
de la commission européenne pouvoir de
contrôle et de sanction des mauvais
élèves c'est le zoom de la semaine
clémentine forissier nous a rejoints sur
ce plateau bonjourbonjour cette
rédactrice en chef de contexte site
d'informations en ligne sur l'europe la
politique européenne vous connaissez les
arcades de bruxelles dites nous comment
cette rumeur a pu arriver en france à
cette rumeur elle n'est pas très
étonnante en fait chacun joue un peu son
match la commission européenne fait
passer des messages par le biais de la
presse pour dire attention là ça se
passe pas exactement comme ça devrait se
passer c'est vrai que les chiffres qui
ont fuité qui ont pu eux qui ont été
annoncées ne sont pas du tout dans les
clous de ce qui avait été prévu
notamment on en reparlera peut-être sur
ce qui concerne le déficit structurel
hors service technique mais c'est ce qui
concerne finalement le déficit quand on
a enlevé les éléments
du moment les éléments liés à la
mauvaise situation économique et donc la
voilà la commission fait passer ses
messages par la commission on dit que
c'est l'entourage du nouveau président
de la commission d'une guerre qui fait
passer ses messages
et pourquoi quel est l'intérêt françois
nogué de lancer ses folles rumeurs
je sais pas si c'est des folles rumeurs
il ya une situation qui est bien connue
d'abord en effet la commission
européenne joue un rôle un peu nouveau
mais qui est nécessaire moi je ne
conteste pas cela parce que si on veut
avoir une monnaie unique qui fonctionne
mieux qu'ils ne soient pas en danger
il faut qu'ils la coordination des
politiques économiques et budgétaires ça
c'est normal après chaque état reste
évidemment mètres de son budget et la
france a engagé un peu un bras de fer
disons le par rapport à la question du
déficit des 3% de déficit du pib
et là je crois que c'est pas à 6 ou 8
milliards parce qu'on va être à quatre
et demi pour cent de déficit par rapport
au produit intérieur brut alors qu'il ya
eu des promesses régulière de faire 3 %
nous nous l'avions dit en 2012 dire
l'année prochaine nous fait 3% alors que
c'est totalement hors de portée ce
n'était pas une bonne politique attend
concrètement la commission européenne de
la france qu'est ce qu'elle veut plus de
réformes moins de dépenses elle veut
plus de réformes et elle attend qu'il ya
un écueil est quand même quelques
mesures un peu phare et surtout je pense
aussi
elle attend de pouvoir répondre aux
états comme les espagnols par exemple
qui ont fait des efforts qui se sont
coupés les bras sous la pression des
européens et qui ont voilà fait les
efforts qu'il fallait que les français
respectent un peu leur engagement on est
quand même les seuls à chaque fois à
reporter d'année en année les efforts
qu'on doit faire donc je pense que ce
qu'elle attend un engagement plus précis
des réformes des réformes peut-être que
structurelles alors on verra ce qu'il ya
dans le projet de loi donné bayonne
macron là qui se prépare on dit à
l'elysée qu' il enfin qu'il ya peut-être
des éléments supplémentaires qui
pourraient être ajoutés on verra ce
qu'il en soit la profession sur les
professions réglementées sur le débat
qui va nous toucher bientôt la forme et
nationale et au sénat bientôt sur le
budget vous n'aurez aucun pouvoir
d'amendement si on comprend bien ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui tout est bloqué
tout est figé c'est parce que nous dit
le gouvernement et c'est pas ce que dit
le principal groupe de la majorité qui
est le groupe socialiste heureusement il
y à du débat parlementaire tous les ans
sur les jeunes marché
il y en a peu ça c'est vrai et c'est
l'héritage d'années et d'années de
déficit je rappelle quand même moi
j'étais député depuis en 2007 dans
l'opposition que le déficit a commencé à
réaugmenter avant la crise
c'est à dire que c'est à l'été 2007
quand nicolas sarkozy a voulu reprendre
ces mesures du paquet fiscal qu'on a
fait re déraper le déficit donc en
france en effet quand on est plutôt en
situation économique relativement
confortable de croissance comme on dit
on ne réduit pas on ne profite pas de
ces périodes pour réduire la dette donc
lorsqu'il ya une crise et qu'on ait fait
là ce serait logique de faire un peu
d'endettement pour financer des mesures
de relance
eh bien on se retrouve complètement
coincé ça c'est une situation qui n'est
plus tenable
on le voit aujourd'hui après il ya
toujours des marges de manoeuvre parce
qu'à l'intérieur de l'envelope vous
pouvez toujours dire heureusement vous
pouvez faire des choix et moi je pense
d'ailleurs que le problème c'est que
depuis 2012 on n'a pas fait assez de
choix ce qu'est ce que bruxelles a
supplanté le pouvoir budgétaire la
commission elle va pas sanctionner un
budget michel sapin a raison quand il
dit que techniquement la commission ne
passait pas elle peut pas fonctionner
mais elle peut sanctionner l'état qui
respecte pas ses engagements mais je
pense qu'il faut pas se méprendre sur
une chose la sanction celle arme
atomique alors a jamais eu
l'hallali l'idée derrière c'est la
négociation et je pense que là chacun
est en train de négocier je pense que
c'est la seule chose qu'on peut lâcher
bon écoutez ça c'est le gouvernement qui
répondra à moi je pense que toute façon
là aussi un an mais on est dans un
mauvais jour de jeu de rôle et là on
vient y en avoir l'explication
transparente serre que tout le monde
joue au chat et à la souris le
gouvernement dise ici depuis deux ans et
demi je vais tenir les engagements qui
sait que c'est intenable est devenu le
gouvernement sait que c'est intenable
elle sauf à avoir commis un jeu de dupes
sauf à avoir cru en un pari qui à mon
avis là est en effet l'erreur
fondamentale de ce quinquennat qui est
que la croissance va revenir demain
matin erreur que quelques mois ou dans
un an prochain d'orgies l'erreur majeure
de françois hollande c'est d'avoir cru
que la croissance pourrait revenir à
nous nous disons depuis deux ans et demi
donc on sent assez à l'aise pour le dire
nous n'allons jamais cru à un retour
comme ça rapide de la croissance qui
règlerait comme par miracle
l'ensemble des problèmes budgétaires
fiscaux financiers du pays
un mot de conclusion c'est pierre
moscovici qui sera chargé une fine et de
contrôler tous les budgets
c'est un petit peu ironique leonid
histoire surtout c'est que l'annoncé a
été faite le jour de son audition à
bruxelles donc c'est le cadeau de
bienvenue
génial oui c'est lui qui va être chargé
de contrôler effectivement si la france
respecte pas ses engagements il a dit
que pour l'instant il se prononçait pas
sur le cas français il a dit qu'il était
là pour appliquer les règles donc on
verra on verra
merci beaucoup aux fleurs tout ce dont
il faut essayer d'arrêter avec nous sur
ce plateau même si vous quand même sur
pierre moscovici ça vous ça vous
surprend au ça vous choque pas sûr que
c'est bon moi je trouve que c'est pas
une très bonne idée de passer
directement enfin directement avec
quelques mois d'écart de ministre de
l'économie non reconduit à ce poste
manifestants ce qu'on considérait quand
même que la politique économique était
pas très bien mené à ministres de
l'économie de l'union européenne puisque
c'est un peu le poste qu'il est censé
occuper au sein de la commission
européenne voilà sur le symbole après
pierre moscovici était un homme
compétent et talentueux donc ça on va
pas le remettre en cause à cette
occasion la même façon que la droite là
dessus juste pour formation comme banon
mais la droite vous avez vu le jeu
qu'elle a joué au parlement européen là
aussi c'est assez malsain c'est je te
tiens tu me tiens vous soutenez un
commissaire à l'énergie qui avaient des
intérêts dans le pétrole et puis
finalement bas nous on va soutenir ça
c'est un jeu qui va faire la commission
européenne ça je le dis au passage elle
est très mal partie autant la nomination
de jean-claude juncker c'est un
conservateur de droite mais c'est la
droite conservatrice qui a gagné les
élections européennes ya une certaine
logique autant là la composition de la
commission européenne
honnêtement elle est très bringuebalante
et elle partait très râle merci que voit
qu'une forissier pour cet éclairage
on va passer à tout autre chose à
françois de rugy c'est une passe d'armes
qui a eu lieu à l'assemblée nationale le
député ump
julia aubert s'est fait rappeler à
l'ordre lors des débats sur la
transition énergétique vous étiez
sûrement dans l'hémicycle son tort avoir
appelé la présidente de séance
sandrine mazetier madame le président
écoutez le 129e messieurs aubert merci
madame
j'en profite dans l'introduction puisque
vous madame ça va pas non plus vous
m'avez mener ce nom non non non alors
monsieur aubert n'avait plus la parole
soit vous respectez la présidence de
séance
soyez un problème
madame la présidente je vise le terrain
rien rappel à l'ordre avec inscription
au procès verbal est un rappel à l'ordre
madame le président avec inscription
j'aurais été prêt je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que bush applique les
règles de l'académie française qui
veulent que la madame la présidente
c'est la femme du président et on
aimerait les demandes d'argent blessé le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale
mais si vous montrez que dans leur
vocation inception s'est mis à mal avec
inscription un rappel à l'ordre avec
inscription au procès-verbal là et si
vous voulez ça peut aller plus loin ce
débat ça peut aller plus loin dit
sandrine mazetier le député en question
lui a écopé d'une amende de l'indemnité
soit touchée sur l'indemnité
parlementaire il ya 139 parlementaire
qui viennent à son secours
ça vous choque ça bah disons que faut
que nous téléspectateurs comprennent
bien que d'abord le fonctionnement de
l'assemblée il repose sur l'application
du règlement et le respect de la
présidence de séance quelle qu'elle soit
qui est tournante de gauche de droite
donc c'est quelque chose de neutre et
d'ailleurs juste avant la veille il y
avait eu un incident avec madame royal
ministre et c'était une présidence de
séance de droite qui a été défendu par
monsieur bartolone président de
l'assemblée nationale donc faut arrêter
avec ces histoires monsieur aubert c'est
un provocateur multirisques mais ça y
est ça qu il sait à quoi il s'attend en
faisant des provocations c'est ce qu'ils
cherchent d'ailleurs il y en a d'autres
des provocateurs au sein de l'assemblée
nationale
mais il y en a qui assume les
conséquences de leurs gestes de fontanès
que ce genre de polémique sur une
question de genre d'ailleurs ne devient
pas un peu assombrir l'image du débat
parlementaire
la séquence attention 239 députés ump
qui n'ont rien de mieux à dire qu'il
faut pas féminisé alors que ça fait
depuis 1998 1 que les titres à
l'assemblée sont faits stylisés et eux
avec plus de presque 20 ans de retard
ils sont encore à demander qu'on parle
de sujets là alors qu'il ya quand même
d'autres choses à faire le règlement
rien que le règlement on avance mercredi
question casse-tête et serpent de mer
comment combler le trou de la sécurité
sociale
la ministre marisol touraine a détaillé
son plan d'action et ses remèdes pour
réduire le déficit du régime général la
branche famille va être mise à
contribution
l'idée d'une modulation des allocations
familiales fait son chemin
ce qui ne plaît pas forcément à tout le
monde réactions recueillies par valérie
brochard et hugo leenhardt ce qui marche
on le casse c'est curieux quand même
pour une fois on a une politique qui
marche qui fait l'envié de l'europe
entière qui permet à notre pays d'avoir
une vraie démographie et bien on va le
cas c'est n'est absolument pas enlever
l'universalité puisqu'il n'est pas
question de revenir sur les prestations
de la politique familiale mais d'en
moduler certaines en fonction des
ressources des familles la bonne réponse
d'abord c'est celle de la réforme
fiscale parce qu'aujourd'hui on
risque c'est que certains ménages qui
ont trouvé un équilibre notamment avec
leurs niveaux de loyers parfois sont
très élevés je le dis quand on a une
grande famille dans des zones très
tendues envahie de nouveaux loyers très
élevés j'utilise aussi l'existence
d'allocations familiales pour conserver
un niveau de vie compatible avec leur
vie de femme et qu'on ne nous fasse pas
le coup de non non non on touche pas à
l'universalité mais on redistribue quand
même si on module c'est plus une
politique verte anne françois de rugy
votre position faut-il moduler les
allocations familiales fonction du
revenu
faut-il imposer les allocations
familiales non moi je ne suis pas
favorable ni à l'intégration des
allocations familiales dans les
déclarations de revenus parce que ça
veut dire qu'on est ce que ça veut dire
ou non d'une main ou larpent de l'autre
ni à la modulation jeu on verra ce que
le débat parlementaire donne vous
demandiez tout à l'heure si avait une
marge de manoeuvre d'un banal et là dans
les débats budgétaires le groupe
socialiste fait une proposition
moi je suis assez attaché avec les
écologistes nous sommes attachés à
l'igas et le coprésident du groupe qui
parle
oui nous sommes attachés à l'égalité des
françaises et des français
les parents les enfants aussi parce que
aujourd'hui il y à des inégalités
vous savez par exemple qu'il n'ya pas
d'allocation familiale au premier enfant
ça c'est une inégalité nous serions pour
qu'il y en ait de façon égale il ya au
contraire des primes en quelque sorte
pour le 3ème cetera et puis de l'autre
côté il y avait la question du quotient
familial
ça nous y sommes revenus et nous avons
bien fait de le faire mais en
contrepartie il faut pas toucher aux
allocations familiales à faire acteur
clé universelle famille et égalitaire il
faut moi je pense que je suis attaché au
caractère universel et égalitaire il ya
trop de défiance dans notre pays
tous les français sont maintenant en
train de se demander si leurs voisins si
leurs cousins leurs cousines ne gagnent
pas plus que ne profite pas plus que du
système de protection sociale et donc
quand on met de l'égalité
on remet de la confiance entre les free
schools estimé que c'était un débat de
fond des réformateurs contre les ce qui
serait plutôt hostile à ces réformes
non je pense que sur la politique
familiale comme sur la politique de la
protection sociale en général depuis
deux ans et demi comme en matière
souvent budgétaires et fiscales on a
préféré bouger un peu l'existant que
transformer les structures existantes
les faire évoluer et faire les réformes
de structure est la plus touchée
petit à petit fait que voulait dire
maintenant mais on fait plus ou moins
sur l'existant nous nous pensons depuis
le début et nous le disons sur la
politique familiale depuis le début que
il faut faire des réformes de structure
et qui permettent éventuellement à terme
de faire des économies et qui remettent
de la justice qui remet de la
transparence entre les français or j'ai
pas quand on fait quand on joue un peu à
la marge plus ou moins eh bien on se
retrouve dans les limites dans
lesquelles vous conseillé aux
parlementaires et au gouvernement de ne
pas toucher à ce socle et awa ce
principe d'égalité police amène à nous
sommes des réformateurs serre nous nous
disons l'égalité c'est à dire dès le
premier enfant
la même somme pour tout le monde et on
se met d'accord pour que ça rentre dans
l'enveloppé budgétaire bien évidemment
mais en revanche on ne touche pas assez
les qualités et à l'universalité en ce
sens vous allez faire des propositions
quand le mauvais sens lesquels par
exemple est-ce que je viens exact
parfois d'un maintenant mais nous
discuterons avec le socialiste nous
discuterons avec le gouvernement c'est
intéressant aussi que cette discussion
ait lieu trop souvent sur le budget on a
l'impression que c'est à prendre ou à
laisser
bon bah là il ya de la discussion tant
mieux dans ces conditions à l'heure
actuelle quelques s'est présentée
aujourd'hui
où voter ce budget sur la sécurité
sociale ou pas attendez nous avons déjà
le budget de l'état comme regarder qui
va être examinée je vous posais une
question de la semaine prochaine aux
sports de la sécurité sociale quelle est
la position des verts nous notre
position elle est simple c'est que nous
travaillons avec des amendements avec
les autres groupes de la majorité avec
le gouvernement pour faire évoluer le
budget de l'état et le budget de la
sécurité sociale et au vu des évolutions
qui ont été faites ou pas eh bien nous
le voterons fou ou pas que ce cycle
duflot j'en parlais tout à l'heure qui
est dans votre groupe dit à l'heure
actuelle tels que c'est aujourd'hui moi
c'est hors de question je ne veux pas je
consulte un avis personnel mais moi je
suis co présidents de groupe
donc je vous
10 l'état de nos discussions au sein du
groupe et c'est la démarche que nous
avons eues depuis deux ans et demi
compris quand cécile duflot était membre
du gouvernement l'année dernière par
exemple nous avions dit le budget n'est
pas votable en l'état parce que sur la
fiscalité écologique la contribution
climat énergie ce qu'on appelait parfois
la taxe carbone il y avait du flou quand
il ya eu la présentation du budget on ne
savait même pas où on allait et nous
avons obtenu dans la discussion que la
contribution climat énergie soit mise en
eau et elle monte en puissance
d'ailleurs au fil des années en irak au
saut et longueur
nous avons voté le berger l'année
dernière vous mettrez la pression et
cécile duflot derrière le souhaitez
alors on va passer à une autre
proposition explosif c'est manuel valls
qui a relancé comme ça en passant le
débat au détour d'une petite phrase sur
le montant la durée des allocations
chômage gros dossiers françois hollande
reste évasif sur le sujet renvoyant le
dossier aux partenaires sociaux les
syndicats eux de voir rouge mari la bat
nous explique tout ça les nouvelles
conditions d'indemnisation du chômage à
peine en vigueur le premier ministre
relance déjà le débat lundi dernier
manuel valls en visite à londres
évoquant off devant la presse
britannique
le fait de repenser la durée et le
montant de l'assurance chômage
à l'assemblée nationale hier il réitère
ses propos c'est un débat légitime
il faut l'aborder sans caricature c'est
une exigence quand on connaît le haut
niveau de chômage depuis des années et
cette réforme c'est celle qui doit
assurer la pérennité aussi de notre
modèle social
même s'il doit se réformer et se
réinventer en déplacement en italie
françois hollande lui reste plus évasif
il ya demain une discussion qui s'engage
entre les partenaires sociaux pour la
modernisation du dialogue social pour
favoriser là aussi la représentation des
salariés mais également la
simplification des procédures
il ya la loi qui est prévue sur
justement la croissance et notamment le
travail le travail du dimanche
il ya suffisamment de sujets pour que
nous soyons bien d'occuper que nous
fillon que nous faisons des réformes
utiles à l'emploi en faux pas des
récentes pour des réformes ont fait des
réformes pour qu'ils aient plus de
croissance et plus d'emploi et notamment
pour les jeunes
pour les partenaires sociaux c'est un
débat à contretemps je trouve que c'est
pas le moment de alors que les nouvelles
règles entrent en vigueur qu elles sont
positives
une première elle tempère m elles sont
incitations positives pas punitive
positive à la reprise d'emploi
on nous dit il faudra revoir les règles
car les renégociation des règles
d'indemnisation chômage passe
obligatoirement par un accord syndicats
patronat
le prochain devrait avoir lieu en 2016
1 on voit le discours un peu
cacophonique entre la position pas très
claire de l'exécutif sur le sujet vous
vous dites quoi il faut ouvrir le débat
c'est nécessaire ou pas du tout moi j'ai
été un peu étonné par les petites
phrases qui sont rapportés dans la
presse et qui sont traités au premier
ministre dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale en réponse aux questions des
députés
il a été un peu plus clair et de fait
donné moins l'impression de vouloir
remettre en cause l'indemnisation du
chômage
moi je vais vous dire notre position
elle est assez simple c'est pas parce
que les indemnités chômage sont trop
élevés que des demandeurs d'emploi dès
chômeurs sont dissuadés de reprendre des
emplois c'est d'abord parce qu'il ya pas
beaucoup d'offres d'emploi mais c'est
aussi parce que trop souvent des
personnes qui reprennent ou prendra une
activité temporaire partiel etc
perdre leurs indemnités ou leurs
allocations
et là ils sont dissuadés en effet de se
remettre en état un sujet tabou
moi je sujet tabou en politique un sayan
c'est pas le sujet oui mais justement
c'est le problème si vous laissez les
postures d'un côté parce que ça
ressemble un peu à une posture un mois
je vais réformer le marché du travail je
verrai faire mal et dynamisation et
chômage peu après qu'est-ce qui se passe
et puis d'un autre côté il ya les
postures de l'autre côté qui disent
attention parce que ça y est on est en
train de faire le modèle britannique ou
que sais-je encore
la protection sociale en france est d'un
haut niveau et nous on est attaché à la
protéger à la finance et aussi parce que
le problème on n'en parle pas beaucoup
c'est l' équilibre financier de
l'assurance chômage qui n'est pas
garanti qu étant lourd déficit est là
aussi comme on a accumulé les difficiles
par le passé on n'est pas capable d'y
faire face quand le chômage augmente
fortement comme c'est le cas
actuellement
mais la réforme des droits rechargeables
au chômage pour les chômeurs c'est une
très bonne rif
or très bonne réforme et ça il faut la
mettre en application maintenant comme
c'était prévu dans la posture le premier
ministre là je regrette que sur ce genre
de propos oui ça donne l'impression
d'être un peu des postures et je pense
qu'en plus lui il a plutôt l'habitude
d'être en effet un réformateur et
pragmatique
donc je ne saurais que souhaiter qu'il
le soit davantage sur ce sujet comme sur
lyon qu'est-ce qu'il fait une erreur de
stigmatiser les chômeurs personnes qui
sont déjà j'ai pas senti son discours
comme une stigmatisation des chômeurs
mais tout ce qui ressemblerait à une
stigmatisation des chômeurs serait une
erreur là aussi le ministre du travail
avait fait des déclarations monsieur
rebsamen qui ont pu semer le trouble à
la sur les contrôles des chômeurs parce
qu'il ya des chômeurs qui c'est le cas
il ya quelques départements aujourd'hui
qu'il faut cette recherche apollo moi je
trouve ça tout à fait normal qu'ils
aient des contrôles à partir en vous
avez une allocation une indemnisation
bien vous êtes contrôlés moi même j'ai
été demandeur d'emploi indemnisé
certaines périodes plus indemnisés à
tout donc je sais ce que c'est mais pour
autant on va pas laisser croire que s'il
y a trois millions cinq cent mille
chômeurs dans la catégorie a et bien
c'est parce que il ya trois millions
cinq cent mille personnes qui ne veulent
pas reprendre un emploi
l'accompagnement à l'emploi en france
est l'un des plus faibles d'europe c'est
qu'il est plus faible qu'en grande
bretagne et sur les seuils sociaux ce
qu'il faut une loi
sujet qui est aussi d'actualité a aussi
demandé le nom mais là il ya une
négociation qui s'ouvre avec les
partenaires moi je suis pour la
négociation entre les syndicats
patronaux et les syndicats de salariés
premier pour le chômage ça devait être
l'an prochain mais bon ici il ya des
choses qui peuvent aboutir parce que des
effets de seuil en effet on voit bien
qu'il ya des entreprises ça moi j'en
rencontre qui me dit je préfère ne pas
passer à 51 et à rester à 48 ou 49
salariés parce que je vais à des
contraintes supplémentaires si on peut
l'y c'est un peu cela oui mais on va pas
supprimer la représentation des salariés
on en a besoin dans les entreprises
d'avoir des représentants des salariés
qui justement permet du dialogue social
et quand il ya du dialogue social
justement permettre de faire des accords
entre les patrons et les salariés
notamment sur les questions d'un de
modulation du temps de travail notamment
sur les questions de conditions de
travail de formation et sera opéré jeudi
avec un enterrement de première classe
celle de l'écotaxe pour ça peut rêver
on imagine que vous avez dû bondir quand
vous avez entendu cette information les
transporteurs routiers ont eu gain de
cause la taxe poids lourds est abandonné
la ministre de l'ecologie ségolène royal
l'a annoncé c'est une suspension si
médiers at-elle dit thomas souliers
c'est lors de cette réunion que tout a
basculé
face à la ministre les transporteurs
routiers réclament l'abandon de
l'écotaxe ils menacent de faire grève et
de bloquer les routes résultats ségolène
royal fait marche arrière
le ph poids lourds est suspendu je
préfère faire cela que devant le pays
bloqué les camions bloquaient les routes
bloquées l'économie et se faire du mal à
eux mêmes je n'étais pas demandeur l'air
de se faire du mal à le même c'est pas
facile de déclencher des mouvements mais
une femme qui sont déclenchées
on sait pas comment ça s'arrête pour
remplacer le ph poids lourds le
gouvernement pourrait taxer les profits
des sociétés d'autoroutes
un groupe de travail a été mise en place
ce recul du gouvernement ne satisfait
personne au sein même de la majorité
je suis très déçu et scandalisé qu'on
gouvernement a décidé de suspendre à
nouveau cette taxe déjà lionel a été
suspendu aujourd'hui la question de
savoir qui va payer
qui va payer pour l'entretien des routes
qui va payer pour les dépenses de santé
la pollution de l'air ça va être encore
une fois les français ce n'est pas
acceptable
je rappelle que l'éco taxe a été votée
par le parlement
il avait été voté à l'unanimité donc on
ne peut pas abandonner du jour au
lendemain
une disposition que les parlementaires
ont voulu cette annonce pourrait tendre
les relations avec les écologistes
en plein débat à l'assemblée sur la
transition énergétique
les débats reprennent ce vendredi dans
l'hémicycle noël mamère a déjà annoncé
qu'en représailles ils ne voteraient pas
le texte
erreur politique ben c'est plus grave
que ça c'est un sujet de fond un la taxe
falloir c'était la mise en oeuvre enfin
en france de façon claire transparente
du principe non seulement pollueur
payeur
mais plus on use les routes plus on
contribue quand même financièrement à
leur entretien et à leur rénovation
voire à leur construction ou devant
dehors grave qu'une erreur politique
ah ben moi je pense que c'est sur le
fond c'est assez grave pour encore une
fois le principe pollueur payeur pour le
budget de l'état
là aussi puisque c'est encore un trou
alors que l'on crée je ne sais pas
comment va leur bouche et on voit bien
ce qui se profile
c'est d'augmenter les taxes sur les
carburants des particuliers alors je
vais vous dire au bout d'un moment
est ce que il faut qu'il ya des
associations qui se créent
d'automobilistes et qui disent nous on
va aller bloquer les zones logistiques
paris ce que vous payez en valais bloqué
en vain on va mettre les français les
uns contre les autres
les camionneurs contre les autorise ap
les autorise subissent déjà la présence
que 200 camions sur les routes ce soir
il est contre l'augmentation de la taxe
sur le diesel on parle de 2 centimes
plus encore deux sorties musclées free
quasiment ses quatre centres et du
rafistolage qu'il y ait une réflexion et
ensuite des mesures prises nous le
souhaitions sur la fiscalité des
carburants avec y compris une baisse sur
l'essence pour inciter à basculer pour
que le marché automobile se rééquilibre
pour que les pratiques changent
évidemment nous nous pensons que la
fiscalité est un outil qui permet c'est
pas le seul
le changement de comportement on l'a dit
souvent c'est quand on touche au porte
monnaie qu'on agit vraiment sur les
comportements mais alors là dire que
pour les routiers simplement ce qu'ils
ont menacé de paralyser la france mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça parce que
votre serviteur que les routiers sont
plus forts que les écologie au delà de
oui mais c'est à veut dire que une
minorité une toute petite minorité des
intérêts particuliers mais tabac non
seulement l'intérêt général mais la
volonté majoritaire ce que si vous
faites des sondages vous verrez que les
français sont très largement
majoritaires favorables à cette taxe
poids lourds soit des résultats veut
dire aussi que le gouvernement et
ségolène royal a cédé à la pression des
lobbys
l'atom d'ériger rien dit sur les
transports ça commence à faire beaucoup
vous avez eu la réforme ferroviaire avec
une grève à la sncf et du coup la
réforme ferroviaire a été
considérablement raboter alors qu'elle
avait été négociée avec la dir est
relatée rection la sncf et les
principaux syndicats vous avez eu le
projet d'air france d'avoir une nouvelle
compagnie européenne
transavia qui a été retirée grève la
sela de l'être toute petite minorité
également et là maintenant la taxe poids
lourds mais je sais pas comment on va
pouvoir réformer le secteur des
transports qui en a pourtant bien besoin
puisque tout le monde dit depuis des
années comment que le tout routier ce
n'est pas une solution que la
transformation des élections et que
surtout qu'est ce qui va remplacer pour
faire preuve d'un peu de verdure
nationale de mettre à contribution les
sociétés d'autoroutes est ce que ça va
100 ça va s'unir mettre à contribution
les sociétés d'autoroutes ça veut dire
que les péages un que payent les
automobilistes et aussi les camions mais
les automobilistes principalement les
autoroutes vont augmenter mais en plus
pour le thriller bark camion bar écoutez
moi j'attends de voir ce que je sais
c'est que les prêts leemans a déjà été
étudié les prélèvements sur les
bénéfices des sociétés d'autoroute c'est
vrai que les bénéfices sont peut-être
très élevé qu'on pourrait en prélever
une partie mais ça sera peut-être 100
millions 200 millions la taxe paulo
c'était un milliard où est ce qu'on va
trouver le milliard par ailleurs le
contrat et comment on va le dénoncer
comme ça sans que ça coûte rien budget
de l'état et bien la réponse est dans la
question
c'est à dire que c'est le budget de
l'état qui va payer ses compères une
recette et on crée une dépense vous
savez que nous à l'assemblée nationale
au sénat on n'a pas le droit de déposer
des amendements qui ferait simplement
perdre une recette ou simplement
augmenter une dépense là l'état par une
décision qui en effet mériterait par
ailleurs un vote du parlement fait
perdre aux aides et créer une dépense
françois de rugy rotonde et christophe
caresche dans le reportage qui dit la
loi a été votée par le parlement
comment plusieurs reprises alors comment
est il possible aujourd'hui de la
supprimer comme ça du jour l'homme parce
que
on s'arroge le droit de dire une
fiscalité qui avait été créée je vais
pas l'appliquer il va bien falloir
repasser devant le parlement va bien
falloir repasser devant le parlement
notamment au moment de la discussion
budgétaire
pour dire les choses clairement qu'est
ce que vous dit rien qu'est ce que vous
direz mais nous nous savons déjà dit au
mois de juillet rendez compte comme en
avait parlé au mois de juillet on a voté
un dispositif au mois de juillet c'était
la taxe poids lourds réduite de moitié
et autant iliaque série là non et là on
va alors ça fait même pas six mois on va
en reparler la semaine prochaine à
l'assemblée lors de la discussion
budgétaire est évidemment nous poseront
les questions concrètes sur le coût de
cette suspension sur ou est ce qu'on
trouve l'argent en contrepartie et ainsi
de suite
nous parions sur les infrastructures de
transport vous savez qu'on a plein de
propositions à faire y compris vous
faire des économies un certain nombre de
projets faramineux jeu bien placé pour
en parler dans mon département le projet
d'aéroport à notre dame des landes où
d'autres alors on multiplie les annonces
d'un côté le grand canal seine-nord ici
le tgv poitiers limoges là bas
l'aéroport de notre dame des landes est
en revanche on réduit les financements
kouakou improvisation non je pense que
ségolène royal avait dit depuis le début
qu'elle était contre cette taxe et que
sa vie je crois que les premiers surpris
c'était les organisations de
transporteurs routiers qui ne
s'attendait pas à cela dans cette
réunion n'a pas déchanté finalement à
bas l long puisque lll a obtenu gain de
cause le rapport à sa position elle
reconnaît pas moi je trouve que c'est
plutôt le gouvernement dans son ensemble
qui du coup c'est un mauvais signal pour
l'écologie mais c'est aussi un mauvais
signal pour conduire des réformes des
changements dans notre pays parce que là
vous donner un sacré coup de pouce à
toutes les corporations si minoritaires
soit haine contre l'intérêt général qui
diront - si je peux bloquer les routes à
rien en vaut mieux pouvoir ce que le
look et les routes bloquées le rail ou
bloquer les aéroports vous avez
rencontré mme royal à bains sur les
autres sujets oui sur ce sujet là on a
toujours eu une divergence on le savait
très bien
1 mais c'est surtout moins par rapport à
l'ensemble du gouvernement nous en
avions parlé d'ailleurs michel sapin qui
est ministre des finances et qui nous
avait dit mais c'est une affaire à deux
milliards d'euros ça crée un trou dans
le budget de l'état entre la perte de
recettes et la dépense d'un dé confiance
aux blues en tout cas j'ai entendu déjà
michel sapin dire que c'était quand même
pas un an ou deux qu'on commençait sa
confiance après sur cette question de la
fiscalité écologique c'est sûr que là la
confiance s'est considérablement
amenuisées
alors va sauter un sentier pas vous si
vous le voulez bien on va parler de
votre e-réputation
françois de rugy m'a parlé de la
e-réputation c'est ce qui se passe sur
le web sur internet sur facebook sur
twitter notamment avec astrid de
vilaines spécialiste du web pour les
chaînes parlementaires bonjour astrid
alors vous êtes penché un petit peu sur
la réputation de françois de rugy au
trouve de tout dans les dom du web
qu'est ce que vous avez trouvé sur notre
invité eh bien on va déjà avait à la
surface du web regarder un petit peu ce
qu'on trouve quand on tape françois de
rugy dans un moteur de recherche on
tombe d'abord sur votre blog plutôt
moderne et bien mise à jour sur votre
page de député sur le site de
l'assemblée nationale
on va avoir tout ça et sur vos réseaux
sociaux qui sont eux aussi très bien
référencé donc c'est vraiment ce qu'on
peut appeler une bonne e-réputation un
monsieur d'origine ne vous inquiétez pas
en revanche on va aller voir quand même
ce qui se passe sur vos réseaux sociaux
vous êtes sur facebook et vous êtes
suivi par 5700 une personne c'est pas
mal mais vous pouvez faire beaucoup
mieux
exactement alors vous êtes quand même
devant votre homologue au sénat ça va
vous faire plaisir un jean vincent placé
puisque lui il est là seulement 1600
fans
en revanche si on va voir si rose entre
la cour et le vrai bon alors que vous
devriez en tout cas barbares accompli
est devant vous regardez 6121 fanal a
donc mille fans de plus que vous il va
falloir rattraper tout ça surtout
qu'elle a été élue bien après donc sur
twitter françois de rugy et en revanche
devant ça irait là dessus vous là là
c'est vrai que vous vous labat emile
follower de plus que barbara pompili
vous êtes donc décidément totalement
paritaire puisque les meilleurs sur
facebook et vous sur twitter on va aller
tout de suite votre profil twitter est
ce qu'on aime le plus c'est bien c'est
votre photo de profil elle a été l'autre
est bien choisi vrai voir en images
fonds vert qui fait écolo et qui se
repère très bien dans le flux twitter
c'est pas mal parce que tout ça là on
est passé un petit peu vite sur votre
page facebook il ya quand même des
dossiers qui traînent dans le vos photos
facebook regarder celle ci alors
évidemment très républicaine a été prise
à tous les coups aux débuts de
l'informatique regard des mugs sur le
côté hémicycle derrière sacrée mise en
scène en tout cas françois de rugy vous
êtes un véritable tweetos vous n'arrêtez
pas de tweet et depuis votre compte
twitter a été ouvert en 2002
vous avez envoyé plus de 14000 message
on a fait le calcul ça fait à peu près
15 tweets par jour c'est beaucoup
certains disent beaucoup trop mais au
moins vous êtes réactif ve vous êtes
notamment illustrés au moment du mariage
pour tous alors que certains à l'ump
proposait d'interdire twitter dans
l'hémicycle vous vous y est totalement
opposé
pardon va devoir avec un tweet c'est
l'interaction entre justement un
hémicycle ça peut très vite devenir une
bulle et le public nous ne sommes là que
parce que nous avons une légitimité
littoral et vous savez qu'à la source de
la transparence je viens de le dire avec
la population tout moment l'assemblée
nationale il ya toujours quelques places
réservées dans le public pour une
personne qui arrive au dernier moment
alors le twitter c'est la prolongation
de ce principe à ce devoir aussi c'est
le bonus avec une photo ou alors cette
photo c'est votre photo de couverture
sur facebook et elle est très
révélatrice regarder françois de rugy
dans la cour d'honneur de l'assemblée
nationale portable à la main certains
disent que vous êtes même totalement
accro à votre smartphone on a donc une
question est-ce que de temps en temps
vous décrochez bah oui bien sûr d'abord
contrairement à d'autres je l'éteins
tous les soirs parce que je le poke les
ont bombardés pendant la nuit et il
m'arrive de ne pas être joignable parce
que je suis en vacances en week-end ou
autre nom ça alors là je veux dire on a
même plaisanté fin août savez qu'il ya
eu un petit événement politique avec la
démission du gouvernement et moi j'étais
en train de faire du vélo dans l'année
en gironde et je restais joignable avec
des moments évidemment liées à la
géographie et j'avais prévu ça de faire
ça en famille et oui j'avais mon
téléphone mais je n'étais pas en
permanence joyal il faut savoir
s'arrêter mais je pense que c'est notre
rôle d'être et notamment twitter permet
ça ou facebook d'être en lien avec nos
concitoyens comme moi je suis dans la
rue on m'arrête je discute je fais des
réunions de compte rendu de mandat c'est
sa vie c'est pas que ça
si c'était que ça mais évidemment c'est
rien côté virtuel mais comme je le dis
toujours à mes concitoyens de nantes
orvault et sauteront dans ma
circonscription vous savez que vous avez
un député sous la main vous m'avez sous
la main physiquement présent ou par
d'autres modes d'interpellations est ce
qu'il ya des tweets que vous regrettez
on peut toujours regretter mais moi
contrairement à d'autres vous pourrez
vérifier je n'en ai pas effacer ou sa du
mari 2002 fois et oui il ya des choses
qui sont parce que moi twitter je
considérais au début que c'était un
autre mode de relation si c'est
uniquement pour copier les communiqués
de presse qu'on fait déjà que mettre un
lien avec cette émission c'est très
intéressant mais ça n'ajoute pas grand
chose en plus et donc moi je voulais que
sont aussi un lien jeu c'est un brin
d'ailleurs un point commun que j'avais
avec cécile duflot on lui a reproché
aussi à elle de faire des choses
personnelles et elle m'a dit quand elle
est devenue ministre qu'elle avait dû
arrêter mais manny toi continue tu es
députés tu as plus de liberté c'est vrai
que maintenant que j'ai plus de
personnes qui me suivent plus de
responsabilités je fais aussi attention
et que oui parfois je m'auto limite vous
fait par rapport à des choses plus
personnelles ou puis-je humoristique qui
compte sur vous quand même pour nos
retraités
merci mais tu vas le strip de vilaines
lee katia se retrouver la semaine
prochaine avec plaisir et très bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires merci à tous de votre
fidélité
pareil